vous présentez comme une sorte de petit
ange venu du ciel alors moi j'ai des
témoignages tout à fait précis des
surtout taper précisent qu'ils disent
que oui vous êtes allé voir des
professeurs à plusieurs reprises pour
contester des notes que vous êtes allés
à la piscine aussi pour exiger je ne
sais pas quoi d'ailleurs mais quand tous
les cas la maître nageuse a dû prendre
quelques jours d'arrêt alors je ne pense
pas que vous l'ayez physiquement molesté
par ailleurs vous avez cette
condamnation définitive à votre casier
judiciaire alors je vois bien que vous
présentez comme un ange du ciel et comme
une victime mais je trouve ça un peu
fort de café parce qu'il ya une victime
dans cette affaire d'accord c'est la
professeure qui à la suite de vos
agissements à laquelle les aléas du ce a
dû quitter la région parisienne un dieu
a été très meurtrie elle raconte cette
entrevue dans le bureau du proviseur
elle dit qu'elle était terrorisée
qu'elle était debout comme une coupe a
causé quercy et que vous trouviez ça
tout à fait normal
à part ça d'ailleurs vous avez dit au
début de votre récit que vous aviez
voulu prendre la chose avec nuance je
suppose que ce que vous appelez la
nuance est d'écrire sur facebook
éducation nationale de merde
effectivement effectivement ça propos
très nuancé je vous en laisse la
responsabilité mais moi je vois une
victime là dedans si vous laissez bien
gentil maintenant d'en arriver on prend
en disant c'est terrible si vous avez
pris 6mois ferme qui ne sont d'ailleurs
pas définitif dans cette affaire au
vocabulaire reconnue comme la web ont
rappelé gilles verdez de la dernière
fois vous êtes tout à fait présumé
innocent mais si vous avez près six mois
ferme c'est primo parce que vous avez
étaient donc condamnés vous avez sept
condamnations dont une pour encore en
2013 menacé des policiers avec des
pistolets et avoir expliqué que le tram
vous et c'est dans le monde nous
expliquer que trappe cela allait devenir
la tchétchénie si on continuait alors je
veux bien vous êtes certainement
quelqu'un de très pacifique mais moi
j'ai des propos de vous qui ne sont pas
très pacifique houzel me vais menacé
c'est également dans le monde de faire
flotter un drapeau noir sur trappe mais
si vous avez prises avec moi c'est juste
parce que six mois c'est parce que vous
aviez un casier à la sortie de
l'audience à la fin de l'audience nous
avait dit devant le procureur devant les
juges d'accord ce qui ne se basent
certainement peut-être pas vous aider
pour l'appel vous avez dit à bas puisque
c'est comme ça je vais prendre un jeu ne
paient le plus cher des avocats je vais
vendre de la drogue pour payer parce
qu'à une amende je crois donc qu'il
voulait diffuser moi c'est bien
d'arriver sur un plateau et se présenter
vraiment avec vos petites ailes dans le
dos mais ça marche pas alors on va voir
mais pour l'instant moi j'aimerais je
vous aime je finis l'année on pardonne
nous répondre sur une frappe mais une
phrase vous dites que elle s'est
platement excusé lors elle récuse le
terme platement fait elle était
terrorisée mais ce que je sais c'est
qu'à l'audience vous n'avait exprimé
aucun regret sur le sort de cette
professeure et pistolet on n'a jamais
jamais me lasser la police avec des
pistolets c'était mes enfants avec des
pistolets à eau et ses sorties du
contexte et c'est oui c'est le monde me
et c'est de l'ironie c'est on va peut
avoir on peut avoir un peu d'humour ils
sont venus et m'ont ils ont pris un
interview ils ont pris le principal
c'était c'est ta question je ne sais
plus qu'est ce qui se passe à trappes il
y avait eu des
défauts et des échauffourées oui des
émeutes on appelle ça comme on veut et
j'étais avec mes deux enfants c'était
l'été il avait deux fusils à eau
et
je leur ai dit ils sont armés c'est la
guerre c'était une boutade c'était
ironique et c'était un journaliste du
monde et s'était jamais et parce que ce
que vous êtes en train de dire madame
c'est à la limite de la diffamation ah
ben quand vous vous dites que j'ai
braqué la police non je le dis avec des
pc au lieu dit des faux pistolet des
tabliers en braqueurs ont alors braquant
la police oui nous avaient dit oui
actuellement fouillée bien donc donc
poursuivre et moi en diffamation qui
sera fait ça sera fait pour d'autres
propos mais oui d'accord elle et
revenons sur sur la joue bien aussi sur
leur chante le deuxième sujet qui est à
aborder et je m'en réjouis parce que ces
accords de la diffamation je revenais
sur mon enfant qui avait dardé des
problèmes de santé
donc il était convenu avec les écritures
les équipes éducatives que mon fils il
est trois notes
dès sa rentrée en sixième qui soient pas
pris en compte le sport
le dessin et la musique qui vous en
conviendrez pas madame et
ses trois notes pour emmener sur le pays
il est dit que vous avez des problèmes
avec les professeurs exactement et donc
ces trois notes depuis la salle sisia
monfils qu'à 14 ans qui entre en
quatrième il a des 17 en mathématiques
des quinze ans en français donc je le
suis et malheureusement il a des
problèmes de psychomotricité il écrivait
encore l'année dernière comme un enfant
de 6 ans voilà et
deuxième trimestre de vastes et 2021
les équipes éducatif ont changé
certaines personnes n'étaient pas là
j'ai encore rappelé le proviseur pour
lui dire il ya un truc qui va pas mon
fils ils étaient démoralisés à la maison
il a une autre qui était de 8 90 alors
qu'il avait une moyenne de 14 ou 15 donc
ça l'a affecté donc il est super
sensible on reviendra s'il voulait
personnellement pour je le dise c'est
son souci donc j'ai appelé il m'a mari
m'a orienté vers son adjointe qui m'a
fait recevoir les professeurs l'a fait
et c'est la seule fois madame allons
allons attendre les professeurs nantes
alors déporté c'était moi c'est la seule
fois où j'ai été à l'école pour
contester une note à la vie revienne
j'aimerais j'aimerais qu'on vienne
chaume des professeurs menthe condamné à
ses côtés pas mais j'ai peur
je peut vous amener des professeurs
jeudi je dis encore jeudi dernier quand
tout ça est arrivé je suis resté trois
heures avec la directrice
de l'école de mon dernier enfant je vais
pas la nommer je suis resté trois heures
à la trouvez vous propos ignobles
déplacer d'accord et donc des séances
d'éducation nationale de même nom mais
l'éducation nationale des verts je peux
penser ce que je veux des institutions
pour isabelle rage quand elle s'est
envolée moi j'ai le droit de me taire
toute critique on a en france madame on
va devoir tout image à droite moi ça je
peux vivre d'autre chose et madame vous
savez cette professeur je n'ai jamais
ciblé un bon vous savez au jugement ce
que j'ai dit quand ils m'ont reproché
tout ça j'aurais dit j'aurais défendu
corps et âme et je reviens à ce qui est
le principal c'est quand j'étais au à
l'école de mon dernier dont encore
l'école primaire je suis resté trois
heures trois heures et moi saveurs de
thé avec le cépage eux pour vous sortir
mon téléphone qui nous sommes le
principal frein aux dames caduc à une
dame qui a dû quitter sa région groupe
allemand s'est inquiété son étiez
d'accord parce que vous avez cru bon de
l'insulté avec nuance bien la formation
allemande a occulté arrêtable caddie
formation parce que 50 automation a dit
ok ok j'avoue qu'elle est partie elle
est partie sur elle et sa famille pour
écouter les matins écouter sur mes posts
si hadj et des insultes si elle des
menaces tout ça c'est dans la procédure
ou et moi on n'a reçu que le dossier
aujourd'hui mon avocat et là moi je le
sais depuis
jamais eu de menace elle est sévère la
peine vous donc quand vous quand vous
traitez de raciste
quand vous traiter quelqu'un de raciste
publiquement quelques semaines après ce
que vous en a dans sa mini vous lancez
pas dans ces pacs et je vais vous le
dire avec le sourire que vous êtes une
racisme bon bah moi vous irez vous en
dit vous avez été juste que j'ai déjà
mon fils m'a tellement avec mes
condamnera je ne vais pas vous allez
entamer pondération elles ont 20 ans et
alors a grandi si vous lui resté figé
dans le passé il ya un passé très très
très épuré et très très court là il n'ya
pas longtemps c'est la personne que vous
y venez vous pendant dix à douze l'air
est encore condamné dernièrement
monsieur zemmour a été condamné à tant
de peine qu'est ce que zemmour qui
intéresse non je ne sais pas bien mais
lorsque vous êtes dans la même sphère a
jugé qu'un terrain pouvez vous respecter
jusqu'au bout ah oui oui oui moi je vous
respecte mais vous vous faites pas
attention aux personnes là n'ont pas du
tout fait quelque chose de faux vous
avez dit chose de factuellement faux à
la dernière émission mais c'était
mercredi alors laissez mission g
mardi ou mercredi
une formation encore une deuxième fois
vous avez dit le matin la professeur la
professeure s'exprime et dit qu'elle
était accablée par son directeur
eh eh oui elle d'imagés les
enregistrements de bfr les gens qui sont
là la france peut se renseigner lundi
matin 8 heures chez bfm elle dit qu'elle
était accablée oui et que même le
professeur le proviseur lui a dit en ces
termes qu'est ce qui vous a pris de m un
rappeur noir entre l'homme de néandertal
et le singe vous le soir sans aucune
verdure au vert vergogne à gauche vous
êtes venus ici sur ce plateau en disant
qu' elle avait le soutien des proviseurs
avec géraldine madame excusez-moi
méchants aliens ça va quoi
géraldine plus les mêmes propos en
disant que cette dame avait eu le
soutien de la direction des deux équipes
éducatives alors j'essaie actuellement
font alors je vais vous répondre ça
c'est du journaliste j'avais en donnera
ce soir d'une journaliste pas
des goûts vous avez un compte au nom de
la raison de respecter les gens qui est
assez amusante mais je vais vous dire je
vous le demande mais pour moi une 30
l'aimions sournoisement faut que cela
nous rend le respect tout jamais
complètement mais je vais vous dire une
chose je vous avais je vous rendre à
moscou madame c'est aussi dans plus
grave que vous
ce qui est encore plus grave que votre
comportement je vous en prie zèle
attitude de l'institution elle est
encore plus grave la naïveté de
l'éducation nationale car refuser de
l'homme le rectorat ayant refusé de se
porter partie civile pour éducation
nationale de merde est encore plus grave
mais moi ce que je vois c'est que depuis
tout à l'heure bon d'accord je vous dis
une chose c'est qu'à cause de vos posts
l'accord de vos pass nuancé
à cause de ses propos extrêmement nuance
est de taille entre attise merci qui oui
oui c'est une vraie nuance éducation
nationale de merde à cause de cela j'ai
pas vu aussi damas a vu sa génétique
madame elle est en dépression elle voilà
des rues minées et le problème c'est
vous